In the case of lactase persistence, one allele
has an effect. The t allele. Even when there's
only one copy. So if you're homozygous thymine or
heterozygous thymine cytosine, as long as you have one
of these thymine alleles or the, the plus alleles.
We're going to be lactase persistent. And therefore, we're going to
be lactose tolerant. Only the homozygous combination of cytosines,
the minus minus combination, are we going to end up
with lactase non-persistence and a phenotype of
lactose intolerance. So out of the three
possible allelic combinations. Two of them result
in lactose tolerance and one of them results
in lactose intolerance. Thus, lactose intolerance is
considered a recessive trait. And by recessive we
just mean it's masked by the presence
of another allele. Whereas the other trait, tolerance,
lactose tolerance or the T allele is
considered dominant because we only need one copy
to see an effect. These two words are used so often in genetics. And the way
we use them is only in a relative
fashion comparing one allele to another. The cytosine
allele is recessive compared to the dominant thymine
allele or T is dominant to C here.
An allele can not be dominant or recessive in isolation. We can only define it
in this fashion when we're comparing it to
another allele. With this information we're actually ready
to look at how lactose intolerance can be
inherited. Let's look back at Kate's pedigree of
lactose intolerance and focus specifically on Kate and
her brother. Using information about dominance and recessiveness.
You should be able to determine what the
possible allelic combinations or genotypes could be for Kate
and her brother. Here in each column, I want
you to select any and all boxes that you
think could possibly apply. Remember, look at the pedigree,
take in all the information you can, synthesize it
with what you know about traits. And alleles that
are dominant versus recessive and remember that a shaded
individual means they're affected by lactose intolerance and if they're
not shaded, they're not affected
by lactose intolerance. They're lactose tolerant.